no kids allowed on the beach
what that's not true i don't know oh
no we never leave each other nothing
separates us
are we there yet you said five minutes
technically
it's been more than five minutes let's
just all start slowing down
[Music]
wow you believe i found this online
i guess it's not that secret of beast
who would leave this from the hotel
they're so rusted
what's happening found stuff from the
hotel in the sun
what happened to her mom i don't know
what happened to her body has decomposed
how quickly can that happen seven years
but she just died
wait where are the kids pranked kara
come here
hey have you seen my children mom i'm
i'm right here
dad why are you looking at me like that
what's happening to us
my daughter just turned six two weeks
ago
whatever is happening to us is happening
very fast you have wrinkles
there's something wrong with this speech
what's happening
people are blacking out going this way
she makes it to the ledge she might have
a chance why she's stopping
what's she stopping can i wake up wake
up
they have to know what this place does i
don't know you're a liar look
what is that a message we never leave
each other nothing separates us
we're connected to something bigger
oh no we're here for a reason
you